okay let's move on now to another
example of just
i don't know what you want to call it
just uh uh more more delusions
um many of you of course know fox news
host tucker carlson he has a highly
rated program on fox news he is seen as
sort of a thinking man's conservative by
many which i know is really difficult to
believe
he did an interview yesterday
with a guy named jason whitlock jason
whitlock i believe sort of originally
yeah sports columnist turned right-wing
pundit jason whitlock he's become a very
popular
um
i i
i feel stupid calling him a cultural
critic but he's become a guy who weighs
in on cultural issues and the right
loves it and why they love it i don't
know i suspect maybe it's he has a fan
base from when he was in the sports
world eager to listen to him
maybe the fact that he's
african-american makes him useful to the
conservative movement as we've seen many
times before for whatever reason jason
whitlock has a quite an audience he
appeared on tucker carlson's program
with tucker carlson and they were
talking about the left
and jason whitlock says i think the left
is satanic
and tucker carlson
agreed
this is
completely outrageous that this is
considered mainstream right-wing
political commentary at this time
let's take a look at it together finding
and destroying this country
what do you think i've always wondered
this like what is the actual support for
the ideas not you know do you like trump
or biden but for example do you think
men can get pregnant or do you think
some races are morally superior to other
races like the core idea is the
democratic party how many americans
actually believe that stuff would you
guess so first of all the questions are
crazy right
uh whether men can get pregnant those
may be the the terms that are being used
in some circles but that it's not really
an issue right i mean okay we can all
understand there might be a trans man
who was born biologically female and
thus
has the equipment with which they could
get pregnant but their their gender
identity could be male but we're not
really talking about whether biological
men can get pregnant the idea of the
democratic party
the idea that the democratic party has
as a core belief that some races are
superior to others of course that's
ridiculous so even the framing is
already crazy but it's just crazy upon
crazy
i don't think
five percent of america believes it
maybe 10
i don't know
tucker i'm gonna say something that
difficult to unpack in this short amount
of time but it's what i truly believe i
think a lot of what the left supports is
satanic i'm just sorry it's it's in
direct objection
tucker says yeah now he'll agree more
but but this is political analysis that
the beliefs are satanic to god and in
direct objection to the judeo-christian
values that were at the foundation of
this country and those christian values
are why we made so much
progress in terms of freedom and
humanity and the way we treat everybody
yes it was hard but our christian values
compelled us to sacrifice our lives for
the freedoms of other americans of
slaves and and through the civil rights
movement our christian values come by
the way that's a civil rights movement
that the right was against but that's
not mentioned here compelled us to take
risks and fight for equality and the
equality of opportunity for everybody i
i just i see a lot of what's going on
here is i'm just sorry i'm a man of
faith i was raised in the church
this stuff is satanic that that's what's
at the foundation of a lot of this stuff
well i'm a pretty mild protestant
personally but i completely agree with
you
[Laughter]
even a mild protestant like tucker says
this is nothing other than the work of
satan especially the gender stuff when
you say you can change your own gender
by wishing it you're saying you're god
and that is satanic i completely agree
this is completely and totally
delusional and there's a couple other
aspects to this one is
the satan stuff
it has q anon vibes it are are they
cow towing are they signaling
to the q anon people that
they are specifically and noticeably on
board
with the satan stuff there's like a
salem witch trials vibe to it and lots
of the stuff they talk about is is very
precisely crafted language like
change your own gender
versus you just address people with the
pronouns they prefer sounds much less
scary sounds much less strange sounds
much less supernatural when you say that
the problem is that people like tucker
to a degree jason whitlock
they're seen as thinkers by the right
which
right now the right is completely
missing any serious voices i mean who
like who is out there right now to be
taken seriously not that we agree with
them
andrew sullivan is a guy i have found
interesting for a long time
is he even really a right winger though
he's like a liberal conservative
catholic gay guy
he's disaffected with the right the
american right he's been disaffected
with it since george w bush does he even
really count doesn't mean i agree with
him on everything or even much
but he at least has had interesting
things to say but i'm not even sure that
he's really even a right winger he
certainly has nothing to do with these
people at this point
you know people like ben shapiro and dan
bongino
these are not real thinkers uh there's
really a dearth right now it's like
maybe neil ferguson and i'm not it's
always risky to do this because i'm not
saying i support them or endorse their
beliefs but i'm just saying there are
there are people who are doing more
serious thought coming to conclusions i
disagree with but this is just gutter
nonsense
at its core it's a very very sad state
of affairs
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled about
because i sleep on a helix mattress at
home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is you
don't have to guess which mattress do i
need which one will be good for me you
take their famous sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position your
back pain issues you might have and they
will pair you with a mattress that will
be perfect for you i took the sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what i needed i often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and i've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so
don't get stuck with something that's
not perfect for you and all helix
mattresses come with a 10-year warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days if you
don't love it but i think you will all
of my viewers will get up to 200 off
your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video